welcome to the show I know black people
we take contestants who claim to know
black people and put their knowledge of
african-american culture to the test the
contestant who answers the most
questions of course wins our grand prize
let's bring them out one at a time
now our first contestant is a professor
of african-american studies and history
at Fordham University the New York City
police officer is a writer for such
black television shows as the Chris Rock
Show and Chappelle's Show okay our next
contestant works make career grocery
store is a DJ and claims to have many
black friends as a social worker and
Wilmington Delaware most of his boys he
goes to school with are black the barber
in Brooklyn who claims that 100% of his
clients are black let's play the game
what is a badonkadonk badonkadonk a
badonkadonk is like a incredibly
attractive ass that is correct
big penis he's talking about my rear
ends I think that is correct you do have
a you know I have to tell you
Washington Heights don't tell the cops
where you got a pop out the belt Oh jump
in the trunk that's what you put your
mug on saddle up and ride he is correct
jump in the trunk but you put your mug
up saddle up and ride for days are all
acceptable answers why do black people
love menthols so much I don't I don't
know that is correct
because that's what Newports are that is
correct is it a fact that they like
menthol to get cigarettes I'm not even
sure I don't know that's great that is
correct no one knows the popular show
good times what did mr. Bookman do for a
living oh he was the head man
that is correct he was a super that is
correct let's see I don't know who
Bookman was on good times so I'm gonna
have to take a guess
was he a janitor that is correct
amazing did not see the show yet knows
that he was the janitor and his nickname
was Buffalo but that is correct and a
bonus point thank you
could you name any of Bookmans nicknames
booth that is correct
Buffalo bud that is correct chichi
chichi I'm checking the judges for cheek
sorry that's incorrect his name with
book min yes Angie Janet
what did they call fat janitor guy
[Applause]
why did black people distrust Ronald
Reagan because he was white that is
correct because he was white that is
correct but he took boys money that is
correct that is correct
why didn't black people distrust Ronald
Reagan he wasn't supposed to be trusted
in the first place he is correct Tito is
pimping easy no that is correct
no that is correct
Big Daddy came but would say it ain't
easy
right have a hard time within myself
yes pimping as a matter of fact thank
you is pimping easy
oh yeah the competition is heating up
but don't go anywhere because we'll be
right back with more I know black people
[Applause]